now a special early mother's day
celebration today the reunion of a mom
and baby who nearly lost their lives to
covet reuniting with the icu team of
doctors and nurses at southern hills
hospital who helped save their lives
an icu team that came together as a
family to help save rowena salas's life
and that of her premature baby oliver
there are moments in your career that
that like make you and they change you
for the better and that will be that day
forever for me thanksgiving day last
year rowena in a dire situation fighting
covet plummeting oxygen levels rushed to
southern hills hospital i know a lot of
us had
been like worried about this family as a
whole we prayed about it physicians
performing an emergency c-section on
baby oliver who was just seven months
old he recovered in the nicu rowena had
to be intubated fighting for her life in
the icu miracle
you know she's obviously invincible
rowena's husband wasn't as fortunate
losing his battle with covid six months
prior with the preemie rowena wasn't
prepared nurses and staff created a baby
registry delivering hundreds of items to
help the family it fills my heart when i
saw them and just when she was
introducing all of them the care that
they provided it makes me tear up right
now even just talking about it
but i'm just grateful for everybody and
everything
celebrating an early mother's day with
her two children and the staff she feels
beyond fortunate as you all know
mother's day last year wasn't so great
i lost my husband the day
after
it's just something i have to work with
and just process
but i am grateful to be here today to be
able to care for my babies